alexandra ocasio-cortez was not in the
main capitol building during the january
6th riot
but her story is still the one leading
the news republican house minority
leader kevin mccarthy slams marjorie
taylor green
but will not remove her committee
assignments and liz cheney passes a test
within the republican caucus with flying
colors i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today
at expressvpn.com slash but we're gonna
get to all the news in just one moment
first
your reminder you should not be trusting
hackers big tech
like look your data is out there and you
should be protecting your data because
there are a lot of people who want to
either steal your data or use your data
to monetize their own programs and you
may not want them to monetize
your data because frankly you don't
trust them that is your prerogative
since it's your data this is why i use
vpn you should use a vpn too the best
vpn is indeed express
vpn everything you search for watch or
click online can be tracked by big tech
companies they can then match your
activity to the true identity
using your device's unique ip address
when i switch on expressvpn with my
computer or phone my ip address is
masked by a secure vpn server that makes
it harder for websites to identify me
the expressvpn app
also encrypts my network data to protect
my sensitive information from being
compromised plus
you can use expressvpn on up to five
devices simultaneously
so multiple users on your network can
stay safe with a single subscription
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it really is easy you install it
click one button you're now protected
it's that simple visit expressvpn.com to
get three months free
on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
to get three extra months for free go to
expressvpn.com
right now to learn more alrighty so the
big story
of the evening last night and of the
morning this morning is this whole blow
up over alexandra ocasio-cortez's story
with regard to the january 6th riot so
we're going to break this down
in all of its aspects because some of
what she's saying is true much of what
the media is saying is not true
and this really goes to how our
fact-checking industry works our
fact-checking industry
here in the the information
dissemination space is extraordinarily
corrupt
extraordinarily corrupt and today is
like a classic story of how our fact
checkers get it wrong and they get it
wrong deliberately
it's pretty incredible okay so let's
begin at the beginning january 6th
riots happen they're awful they're evil
their acts of criminality
alexander ocasio-cortez this week she
put out a 90-minute
instagram video in which she explained
her harrowing experiences
and it would not be difficult to
conclude if you did not know the
geography of the area that she was in
the capitol building itself
now let's bring up a quick map okay
because capitol hill
actually is a bunch of places right
capitol hill is not just the capitol
building capitol hill
is a bunch of different places so for
example the
capital hill bill like the actual
capital building
is not lo not all congressional offices
are actually located inside the capitol
building
some of the congressional offices are
located in what's called the longworth
building
another set of congressional offices are
located in the cannon building
alexander ocasio-cortez's offices are
in this map you can see the cannon house
office building
that is located all the way down first
street and across independence avenue
it's a little bit of a walk it's about
0.3 miles
it's not like right next door but it's
also not super duper far away there are
tunnels that connect
the us capital building to the cannon
house office building there's also the
longworth
longworth house office building and that
houses a bunch of
different congressional offices there's
also the rayburn house office building
right all of these are located
along independence avenue they are not
part of the capitol building they're
part of what's called the capital
complex meaning
that it includes you know everything in
the immediate area that is connected via
tunnels
okay so i've taken those tunnels they
exist
on the day of january 6th cannon house
office building was not breached
okay the riders did not breach canon
house office building did not breach the
longworth house office building they did
not breach the rayburn house office
building they breached the capitol
building itself
okay so if you watched aoc's live stream
she never says that she's in the capitol
building so let's be clear about this
she didn't lie and say that she was in
the capitol building some people are
saying that she lied
she didn't what she says is that she
felt like she was in imminent fear of
her life
okay and listen you are entitled to your
feelings it doesn't mean your feelings
are entirely justified as we will see
when you watch katie porter who is in
literally the same office because as he
ran to her office they seemed to have
very different attitudes about what was
going down
that day here was alexander
ocasio-cortez describing her experiences
on the day of january 6th
and so i hide behind my door
like this like i'm here and the bathroom
door starts going like this
like the bathroom drawers behind me or
rather in front of me and i'm like this
and the door hinges right here
and i just hear where is she where is
she
and um this was the moment
where i thought
everything was over
okay and then she continued and it turns
out that the person who was banging on
her door was actually a capital police
officer now we know from the day of
the capitol police officers were in fact
getting people to
leave the cannon house building and move
to safer locations but ocasio-cortez
what she said
should continue on in that video she
said that after the capitol hill police
officer came into the office said quote
things weren't adding up
like she added there was no partner
there and no one was yelling he wasn't
yelling like this is capital police he
was looking at me and all this anger
and hostility she said did he not say he
was capital police on purpose was he
trying to actually put us in a
vulnerable situation
all these crazy thoughts go through your
mind are some offices safer than others
because they have
white sounding names or male sounding
names okay so so this is the way that
she tells the story okay now
she heads on over to katie porter's
office which is right next door so
here is katie porter on msnbc describing
the exact same set of circumstances
except from her perspective
first she you know she saw me um she and
we waved i went into my office and a
couple seconds later she knocked and
she said you know could we could we come
in and i said of course
um and she began to deal her staffer was
trying to describe what had happened
and alex is really usually like
unfailingly polite
um and very personable and she wasn't
even really talking to me she was
opening up doors and and i was like can
i help you
like what are you looking for and she
said i'm looking for where i'm going to
hide
okay so here is the thing katie porter's
reaction when alexander ocasio-cortez
burst in is not okay let's get in here
let's barrier up all the doors
they're out there they're coming it's
like what's going on now
oh why are you doing this okay so is
katie porter reacting inappropriately i
don't think so in fact aoc describes how
she walks in
i believe and katie porter's sipping
coffee right and so
and and then katie porter is being told
by aoc i'm looking for a place to hide
and aoc is saying i'm afraid i'm gonna
die today i always wanted to be a mother
and then apparently aoc didn't have
sneakers she was wearing high heels
and so she said to katie porter do you
have any sneakers and katie porter went
to one of her staffers and had her give
her her sneakers which like
imagine you're that staffer like if you
actually think that the danger is that
grave outside and it's like okay
you know staffer i know that you're
wearing sneakers right now
let's be real about this aoc has a lot
of instagram fans and you are a no-name
staffer in katy porter's office i'm
gonna need you to give those sneakers to
alexandra ocasio cortez because let's be
real here
she has huge twitter following i mean
the the woman has an enormous media
presence and you
you you anonymous staffer you just have
sneakers so you know what i'm gonna need
you to turn over those speakers okay
those sneakers in any case what aoc says
is not actually lying right so i've said
this already
her emotional response may not be well
calibrated
i mean that's possible or maybe it's
really well calibrated and maybe she's
just
maybe that's how she responds
emotionally people respond emotionally
in crisis circumstances
differently okay to give everybody the
benefit of the doubt some people react
like katie porter does and they sit
there and they're like i don't even
what and some people react like aoc and
have a heightened
sense of panic fair okay that's okay
you're allowed to do that for sure
hey nancy mays who is two doors down the
representative
she said aoc made clear she didn't know
who was at her door breathless attempts
by the media to fan fictitious news
flames are dangerous she said my office
is two doors down
insurrectionists never stormed our
hallway egregious doesn't even begin to
cover it
is there nothing the msm won't
politicize because here's the way that
newsweek
covered what aoc said here's newsweek
ocasio-cortez said rioters actually
entered her office forcing her to take
refuge inside her bathroom
after her legislative director geraldo
benia chavez told her to hide hide
run and hide as members of the mob
banged against the door ocasio-cortez
believed this was the moment where i
thought everything was over okay so the
media
immediately spin up aoc's story where
she didn't lie again
aoc's original statement maybe and
maybe a uh in out of out of proportion
emotional response to the events that
were actually happening
immediately surrounding her that's not a
lie right it doesn't make it a lie the
media immediately begins spinning this
up
the media immediately begins spinning
this into alexander ocasio-cortez was in
her office the riders were right outside
her office they were trying to bang down
the doors now
here is the thing why was alexander
acosta's
ocasio-cortez's story leading the news
for several days here
and there were several washington post
editorials about how brave she was and
how wondrous she was
why was she leading the news of all the
people who had relevant stories to tell
on january 6th
she is like somewhere near the bottom of
the list because again she was not in
the capital building itself
there were legislators who are in the
capitol building itself if you were
looking for personal harrowing
experiences presumably you would start
with them just to be completely
objective and fair you would start with
the people who are in the most immediate
physical danger
and then you would move on down the list
right but that's not the way that the
media treated this and the media treated
this this way
because alexander ocasio-cortez is
willing to say completely unhinged
things
not about her own personal experiences
per se but she's willing to say unhinged
things
about other people right so she will
just throw out implications like ted
cruz wanted to murder me
or like ted cruz and josh halley are
just like the person who sexually
assaulted me and the media lapped this
crap up the media
want to make that the number one story
they love the implication
right so they don't fact check where she
was at the time that's not important
what is important to the media is the
stuff that is not fact checkable
meaning her implication which is that
all republicans are incipient murderers
who wanted her personally killed
and or are like rapists who want their
victims to just forgive and forget right
that's the part that the media loves
that's why the media spun it up
if alexander ocasio-cortez he just
described her circumstance and said
listen i was in the
cannon house office building it's
located about .3 miles away it's like a
six-minute walk there's some capital
tunnels but those were protected by cops
building wasn't breached at any point
but i was i was in fear because i know
that i'm really famous and i know a lot
of people send me death threats and it
freaks me out so when that happened
i went and i hid in katie porter's
office and listen i was scared
do you think that would have made the
same headlines of course it wouldn't
have made the same headlines the reason
it became a headline is because
she said she was a sexual assault
survivor and therefore
the people who were not on her political
side of the aisle that she dislikes are
just like
the person who sexually assaulted her
right that's why it made headlines
that's why you got the bravery of
alexandra ocasio-cortez
routine from the media that's the reason
not because of the actual circumstances
that surrounded her and this is why you
have a piece from
thelily.com saying in alexander
ocasio-cortez these survivors found a
voice
i felt with her the deeply vulnerable
pain of telling someone
right this was also linked by the
washington post ocasio-cortez's explicit
language around trauma may help
facilitate other women's healing
experts added and so it was all the
ancillary stuff that aoc said which
really truly was i believe immoral i
don't think that comparing
fellow fellow congress people to rapists
is a useful enterprise i don't think
suggesting
that ted cruz wants you dead is a useful
enterprise but the media loved that kind
of stuff right that is the reason
why her account became the account
okay so over the course of last night a
bunch of people pointed out
by the way she wasn't in the capitol
building and
the and some people went
further and said you know and that means
that she was exaggerating what she was
what she was saying she was exaggerating
her experiences again
she she could have legitimately felt
what she was feeling doesn't mean the
feeling was totally justified but she
could certainly have felt that i'm not
doubting the veracity of her feelings at
the time
and her account is accurate so far as i
can tell
she she just it's somewhat misleading in
that if you are reacting as though there
are capital rioters directly at your
door and the closest they are is three
tenths of a mile away and you are
protected by several layers of police
it's not quite the same thing right and
you can see why people would draw that
conclusion like the entire media drew
the conclusion that she was actually in
the middle
of sort of the most dangerous area here
from from her description
so here's what happens this starts to
trend right
on twitter the hashtag alexander
ocasio-smole starts the trend as in
jesse smelly
right jesse smallett the the actor who
described how he was
how he was lynched with the noose in the
streets of chicago by a couple of manga
hat guys and it turns out to be complete
nonsense now that's an exaggeration in
and of itself right i mean she's not
jesse smallette she didn't claim that
the rioters had bust in there
and she describes her feelings
throughout the ordeal and you can think
that those feelings are unjustified
i hear that but her feelings are her
feeling it doesn't mean she lied
i keep saying that over and over because
i want to be very clear about what is
true and what is false unlike the fact
checkers we're going to get to in just
one second
okay so here is where things go wrong
for alexandra ocasio-cortez we're gonna
get to where things actually go wrong
in terms of where she moves not just
beyond the pale with with regards to her
accusations against fellow members of
congress and throwing out implications
like police officer trying to get her
killed
or that or that people are going office
by office looking for
non-white non-male names in order to
attack adults we'll get to
where she actually started to get into a
very dicey territory last night
uh via how she approached this social
media problem in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that you
could be saving hundreds of dollars per
year
as in like up to 800 bucks a year simply
by switching your cell phone coverage
and you can have the exact same coverage
same tower same deal
why aren't you if you're with att
verizon t-mobile you're just spending
too much money
your family could save over 800 bucks a
year just by switching to pure talk usa
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number
but you will save a fortune by the way
puretalk is the top-rated wireless
company
by consumer affairs with the absolute
best customer service team based
right here in america sound good well it
does get better because right now you
get unlimited talk text and six gigs of
data for just 30 bucks a month when you
say yourself what if i use more than six
gigs of data well if you go over on data
they're not going to charge you for it
so really you have nothing to lose
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
off your first month dial pound 2 5 0
say keyword ben
shapiro again go to dial pound 2 5 0 say
keyword ben shapiro
get involved with pure talk usa you'll
say 50 off your first month and hundreds
of dollars down the road
pure talk usa they are simply smarter
wireless okay so here is where
alexander ocasio-cortez starts to really
lose it
okay so she sends out an email to from
team aoc
to her entire email list and her email
asks her constituents to contact anybody
in the fact-checking world
or in the social media world and try to
get them to censor and remove tweets
that suggest that she was not in the
capitol building
hey i'm serious here's what she wrote as
we speak right-wing operatives with
millions of followers on social media
are spreading flat out lies and
misleading information about alexandria
but with your help we can force twitter
and facebook to take action and enforce
their own rules
what's so frustrating about these
attacks is that once the truth comes out
so few people get to hear it
hundreds of thousands or potentially
millions of people who have already seen
or shared the misleading tweets or fake
news articles okay so first of all
the irony of alexander ocasio-cortez a
person who has said on national
television
that actual facts matter less than moral
truth
there is some irony here this is a
person who has spent the entire
the entirety of the last several weeks
claiming without evidence
that fellow congress people so far as
i'm aware she's provided no evidence of
this that fellow congress people
were in on the riots that ted cruz
wanted her murdered attempted to have
her murdered that josh halley and ted
cruz are like her own sexual assaulters
and here she is being like i can't
believe people are putting out
misleading information
that's really upsetting but here's where
it gets dicey what is the misleading
information
okay apparently the misleading
information is that
she was not in the capital building so
she keeps insisting that she was in the
capitol building
because in fact she was part of the
capital complex right this is what she
tweets out
she tweets out well you know guys i mean
it's connected by tunnels
she says this is the latest manipulative
take on the right they're manipulating
the fact that most people don't know the
layout of the capital complex we were
all on the capitol complex the attack
wasn't just on the dome
the bombs trump supporters planted
surrounded our offices too okay so a
couple of things there
one we have yet to find the evidence of
who actually planted the bombs
she can make an assumption it was trump
supporters but that actually is not
publicly available information
so that in and of itself is misleading
information
and when she says that we were part of
the capital complex and therefore
they were trying to attack the capital
complex in general
nancy mace was on the same floor she
says the rioters did not breach the
building
okay reporters at the time said the
writers did not breach that building
again this is not to say that she
couldn't have been justified or at least
she couldn't have felt legitimately and
authentically in danger
again people react to crisis in
different ways but what she is now
saying which is that
oh yeah you know people are saying i
wasn't in the capitol building how dare
they
well i mean were you or were you not in
in the capitol building
it's called the capital building it's
not called the capital complex when
people say
the rioters stormed at the capitol
building they mean the capital
building like a building because
they don't mean the complex right i mean
so so she is now
now she's misleading so she puts out a
this email and she says we need your
help here's what you can do to help us
combat
this campaign of disinformation and
others in the future scan your social
media to find posts with this misleading
information
especially those using the trending
hashtag
it's funny how alexander ocasio-cortez
is you know her emergency mode kicks in
when she's trending for the wrong
reasons on twitter as somebody who
trends on twitter frequently like once
every
three weeks once every month i can tell
you that the best thing you can do with
a twitter trend is basically ignore it
that's pretty much the best thing you
can do with the twitter's one but she is
uh
instead she says she wants all of her
followers to basically spam facebook and
twitter and get a bunch of stuff taken
down
which is not a great look for a sitting
congress person she says don't tweet any
hashtags yourself because we don't want
them to spread further
identify any posts that are threatening
or harassing and use the built-in report
features
to flag them for the moderators facebook
and twitter both have built-in tools
for reporting posts and tweets that
break the rules
the sad thing is that a lot of damage
has already been done people have
already been misled and radicalized they
believed the lies to a point where their
hatred could someday boil over into
violence ah so now she's going to say
that if you point out that she was not
in the capitol building
itself that you are one of the kinds of
people who distributes information that
ends with the january 6th riot
i mean that's that's pretty manipulative
stuff right there
she says we can keep calling out
photoshop tweets fake news articles
misleading posts when we see them okay
now here is where the fact checkers get
involved
okay so it used to be that fact checkers
checked
fact right that was the thing that they
used to check was the facts
not implications they didn't fact check
emotional suggestions
they didn't check fact check subjective
takes
what they used to fact check was you
know facts
and there are many things that could be
fact checked here so for example you
could fact check whether she was
actually in the capitol building at the
time
or you could fact check whether she lied
at the shoes in the capitol building at
the time
right the answer on the first issue was
not in the capitol building at the time
and two
i don't see evidence that she lied about
being in the capital building at the
time and both of those things can
simultaneously be true but that is not
what the fact checkers do
because the fact checkers are just
democratic operatives they are just
completely full of crap so here is how
the fact checkers do their business
this is how they have decided that they
are going to pervert the system and
understand it matters what the fact
checkers do
because when we are talking about how
you receive information
you will see that sites like facebook
and like twitter they use
left wing fact checkers in order to
knock down right wing
sites knock down conservative sites and
those left-wing fact checkers are taken
as though they are objective
metrics for the news that facebook was
using
during the month after the election they
were using what they called their their
trusted news metric it's like this is
quality news metric
and the way that they measured that is
they went to basically a bunch of
left-wing fact checkers and then they
would downgrade any news source that got
fact checked a lot
so naturally cnn never got fact checked
but daily water got fact-checked a lot
because it turns out that the people at
places like snopes and politifact hate
the dailywire but love cnn
because it's all subjective and so here
is the fact check from snopes it's a
perfect example
of how the fact checkers are just they
just lie by implication
and sometimes openly it's pretty amazing
okay so snopes puts out a piece
on this whole silly debacle right here's
what they say
did aoc exaggerate the danger she was in
during the capital riot
okay so first of all you can't
fact-check that there's literally no way
to fact-check
that particular question because that is
a matter of subjective opinion
did aoc exaggerate the danger she was in
during the capital riot
so you could say no she didn't
exaggerate the danger that she was in
during the capital riot because the
capital rioters were violent they were
looking for congress people
theoretically they could have gotten in
and it could have hurt her or you could
say no she absolutely exaggerated the
danger she was in considering no one
breached that building there were other
congress people on that level none of
them are acting like aoc did
so maybe she did exaggerate so there's
really no way to fact-check that right
that is a subjective matter of opinion
whether alexander ocasio-cortez
exaggerated the physical danger that she
was in
in the account that she told of what was
going on
now again there are fact-checkable
things that snopes could do here they
don't do that they frame the question
as a fact check about emotional response
you can't fact check emotional response
which is why i have said over and over
and over
that aoc did not lie right that is a
fact check aoc did not lie
okay you may think that her emotional
response is off kills her that does not
that does not mean that she lied right
there are ways to fact check that are
objective
that's not what the fact checkers are
doing so says aoc was targeted with
another round of bad faith smears
after giving an emotional firsthand
account of her experiences during the
capital riot
okay so let's get to the actual fact
check from snopes because it is so
indicative
of how exactly snopes and these fact
trackers operate
so here's what they do they say claim
this is snopes fact check of the whole
aoc
silliness claim alexander ocasio-cortez
exaggerated the danger she was in during
the january 6 2021 capital riot and that
she quote wasn't even in the capitol
building when the rioting occurred
okay well those are two claims that you
are now fact-checking and you are
lumping them together
so that you can pretend that a factual
claim is a non-factual claim
right there's two claims that snopes is
now fact-checking one is that she
exaggerated the danger that is not
fact-checkable and the other is a
fact-checkable statement that she was
not in the capital building when the
rioting occurred
it is true she was not in the capitol
building when the rioting occurred how
do i know this
because snopes acknowledges this here is
what snopes says
first of all they say it's mostly false
okay the claim is alexandra
ocasio-cortez exaggerated the danger she
was in during the january 6 2021 capital
riot and that she wasn't even in the
capital building when the rioting
occurred
rating mostly false mostly false okay
here's what they say
what's true ocasio-cortez wasn't in the
main capital building where the house
and senate chambers are located
wait what now so literally you are
fact-checking the question of whether
she was in the capitol building
and then you say it's true she wasn't in
the capitol building but you rate the
claim
mostly false here's the best part of
this i love this so
they fact checked one of the tweets that
came from daily wire because of course
the idea
here is to keep dinging and downgrading
conservative sources even when they are
telling
the objective truth so here is the daily
wire tweet that they called misleading
why is it misleading by the way it's
misleading because the conservative side
put it out here is what the daily wire
tweeted you ready for this
this is what they are fact checking as
misleading quote
report aoc was not inside capital
building during breach on january 6th
that's the entirety of the tweet report
aoc was not inside capitol building
during breach on january 6th
now let me read to you again from what
snopes says is true
quote ocasio-cortez wasn't in the main
capitol building
why it's almost as though it's true when
you say it but misleading when i say it
so you're just full of that's the
that's the impression i'm getting from
you snopes like i'm getting the
impression that you fact checkers very
often are more interested
in fact-checking implications than
fact-checking facts because you want to
come up with a pre-ordained conclusion
and that is that anyone who criticizes
alexander ocasio-cortez isn't just wrong
they are a liar they are saying untruths
right that no that is not the way any of
this works but this
is a dangerous thing that is happening
right now in the country because what
you're seeing i've been talking about
this for a while
these shift from disinformation
to misinformation right it's just it's
misinformation you know it's like it's
just it's it's
information we don't like that shift is
so dangerous
and what the left has been doing what
the fact chapters have been doing what
the social media sites have been doing
is they've been fact-checking
implications whenever you see a fact
check that says
needs context you know this is now a
political it's now a political exercise
because either a claim is true or it's
not when you say that a claimant needs
context that is a claim
that i will discuss on the show right i
mean that's what the show is for is to
give context to various claims
we'll discuss it but context is a
political argument there are various
takes on what context is appropriate to
place things in
there are certain things in life that
are factually true and certain things in
life that are factually false it is
factually true alexander ocasio-cortez
was not in the capitol building
then there is the secondary claim which
is did she exaggerate
what happened to her and there you have
to really examine her emotional response
was it appropriate for the time how are
other people at the area responding
right all of that is a matter of opinion
but instead what the fact checkers do is
they wrap all that up in a ball and then
call it false
a thing that is objectively true which
is that she was not in the capital
building at the time now why am i making
a big deal out of this
i'm making a big deal out of it for a
couple of reasons one the manipulation
of truth actually matters
it matters an awful lot and when you say
that there are fact checking sites that
are out there to fact check
and when you say that objective truth is
really just your opinion
that is orwellian kind of stuff the
redefinition of truth to mean anything i
like
and the redefinition of falsehoods mean
anything that i disagree with
is a dangerous thing especially when you
have the mechanistic power when you have
the
institutional power to ram down your
version of truth meaning your opinion
on everybody else that is a dangerous
dangerous thing
it also happens to be that the media
have people that they love and the fact
trackers have people that they love
and they will manipulate these stats in
order to achieve a given end
you see you see this with joe biden if
joe biden lies or gensacki lies it's not
a lie it just requires a little bit of
context you're just not getting the full
idea
and if republicans say something that is
true
but has the wrong implications according
to the media it becomes a missing
context
or mostly false statement and then that
is used to downgrade your ability to
access the information
it is a mind f okay that is what is
going on right now
and it's it's really something that we
all need to watch out for
because it's it's again when when this
stuff is used to censor
when you have by the way active congress
people sitting in the federal government
asking for censorship of claims that
they don't like
that happen to be true that's that is
not a good look
that is not a good look at all okay
meanwhile
controversy is not restricted to one
side of the aisle
last night the house republicans decided
not to remove marjorie taylor green from
from any of her committee assignments
now there has been a sort of rich debate
inside republican circles
about whether marjory taylor green ought
to be removed from her assignments on
committees
normally the way that this works inside
congress is that each party decides
which members sit on what committee
right the now the way that it actually
works in actuality
is that the majority of the house has to
vote in order to seat somebody on a
particular committee
right so the committee assignments are
put forth the house as a whole votes on
that
question so theoretically if you have a
house republican majority they can
decide to deny a seat on a particular
committee to a particular democrat but
historically that's not the way this is
done
historically in in for purposes of
comedy basically you have democrats
decide who they want on a particular
committee and republicans decide who
they want on a particular committee
and then everybody just sort of votes
for whatever the parties
have already assumed to be true and so
for example when ilhan omar who is a
garbage human being an anti-semite when
she was
was being openly anti-semitic the
republicans
did not respond by saying okay well we
can't seat her in her in
a committee we're going to deny her a
seat on a committee right they didn't do
that
just a sense of reality here okay that
did not happen
the democrats right now are talking
about doing that with margery taylor
green but
last night was more about what the
republicans did so the republicans had a
choice do we
take away the committee assignments for
marjorie taylor green or do we allow her
to have
her committee assignments and there's
sort of interesting debate there which
is
can you punish somebody by taking away
their committee assignments for stuff
they said before they were elected to
congress
there are some people that i respect who
are like nah you can't really do that
because
it's just a bad precedent you really
don't want to be doing that
or you know we have to give them a
chance to actually perform if they do
this while they're a congress person
then we can remove them from their
committees and then there are folks who
say listen
just because somebody gets elected to
congress doesn't mean that the party has
to honor them with particular committee
assignments
i tend to fall into the latter category
which i believe that parties should hold
their own members accountable with
committee assignments
for stuff that they do right i think
that the democrats should have denied
ilhan omar a committee assignment
and i think that the republicans should
have denied marjory taylor agreeing a
committee assignment kevin mccarthy
didn't put it up to a vote
he decided instead that he was going to
avoid that particular controversy but he
did put out a statement blasting
marjorie taylor green's
old statement so according to the new
york times representative mccarthy the
top republican on wednesday condemned
representative marjorie taylor green's
past conspiratorial and violent comments
he declined to take any action against
her on the eve of a vote forced by
democrats to remove her
from congressional committees mccarthy
said in a lengthy statement past
comments from and endorsed by marjorie
taylor green on school shootings police
violence and anti-semitic conspiracy
theories
do not represent the values or beliefs
of the house i condemn those comments
unequivocally
in the same statement mccarthy
criticized democrats for moving
unilaterally to kick green off the
education and budget committees
calling the action a partisan power grab
are you saying okay well we're not going
to kick her off
because we have debate inside the halls
here but um you guys don't get to kick
her off because that really does break
with all past precedent
and he pointed out by the way you guys
didn't kick out your own folks
right he says you know rashida talibil
hanomar are still sitting on committees
cynthia mckinney who was a blatant
anti-semite who believed in conspiracy
theories sat on powerful committees
we let you guys put her on the
committees you wanted to do the house
majority typically does not deny the
house minority the ability to assign
people to its own committees okay so
that's mccarthy's statement
on this particular matter and this of
course leads the entire media to say
okay well now this is the party of
marjory taylor green
no when you condemn her comments and
when you rip on her comments and when
you say that she's a cancer in the
republican party as mitch mcconnell did
or when you condemn
wholeheartedly her statements as
mccarthy did it is hard to say that this
is a person who is the entirety of the
republican party
does that mean that they did the right
thing in allowing her to keep her
committee assignments i don't think so
and for folks who are saying well yeah
but the democrats the democrats let
right but i'm not a democrat i'm a
republican i would like for the
republican party
to actually hold its own members
accountable so they don't say stuff like
this in the future
and so they stop all this if she wants
to earn her way back into committee
power well then she can
show how about six months of like not
saying this kind of stuff how about that
and that seems like that would be a good
indicator she did issue an apology
yesterday apparently she went in front
of the house members
and she talked about how she was drawn
into conspiracy theories and all this
kind of stuff
and that's nice but i'm a truth but
verify kind of guy
which is okay trust but verify kind of
guy like okay that's nice
now show me that that you actually
believe this and then we'll talk about
this a couple of months
down the road so uh marjorie taylor
green
told the the house republicans that her
her statements did not represent her
apparently she received some sort of
standing ovation from a small contingent
in the among the house republicans
steining hoyer of the democrats however
is going to ram this thing down because
again for democrats the goal isn't to
abide by any sort of common rules even
if those rules cut against your interest
the goal is to just ram home at this
idea
that the entire republican party is the
party of marjorie taylor green
which by the way is the reason i think
that the republicans should disassociate
from having her on the committees
i think that it's been a boon for
republicans the democrat i mean as a
political matter
i think it is very good for republicans
the democrats refuse to oust ilhan omar
and shoot it to lead from their
committees
i think the democrats should own it you
want to put her on the cover of rolling
stone with nancy pelosi go ahead and do
it man
because at least that way we know where
you stand i think for that reason that
it was important that steve king be
denied his committee assignments
for example anyway standing hoyer is
ramming this four he says i spoke to
leader mccarthy this morning
it is clear there is no alternative to
holding a floor vote on the resolution
to remove representative green
from her committee assignments the rules
committee will meet this afternoon
the house will vote on the resolution
tomorrow hours later mccarthy announced
answered hoyer's action by announcing no
new repercussions for green with a
statement that amounts to a slap on the
wrist for the first term
republican and spent more time
criticizing democrats than her past
comments questioning if the pentagon was
struck by a plane
on september 11th or advocating for the
assassination of top democrats et cetera
et cetera
mccarthy said that her past statements
do not represent the values
or beliefs of the house republican
conference he said he would hold her to
her word
that she'd be more careful with her
comments going forward which really does
smack of the kind of
almost exactly the reaction that nancy
pelosi had to ilhan omar
oh well she sort of half walked it back
and said she was misinterpreted so
we'll let it go right i don't like that
kind of activity
on either side of the aisle and i'm not
gonna hold republicans to a different
standard than democrats
on this one i will say the democrats are
holding republicans to a different
standard than they hold themselves
for sure right they are moving to oust
taylor green
from the committees the republicans have
assigned her to well meanwhile elevating
ilhan omar at blatant open anti-semites
to the house foreign affairs committee
where she says we'll get to more of that
in a second because two things can be
true at once one the republican party
should have done something about it
two the democrats are the world's
biggest hypocrites on this kind of crap
i mean it's truly hypocritical and
astonishing we'll get to that in just
one moment first let us talk about the
fact that right now you don't want to be
going to the post office in fact
why would you want to go to the post
office and stand in line when you can
just do stuff from home
and mailing stuff from home is super
easy with stamps.com
stamps.com allows you to mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters
ship packages pay a lot less with
discounted rates from usps
ups and more stamps.com has saved
businesses thousands of hours tons of
money with stamps.com you get the
services of the post office and ups
all in one place plus big discounts on
mailing and shipping rates here at daily
wire
we've been using stamps.com since 2017
no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups directly to your
computer
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business simply use your computer to
print
official us postage 247 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it
and then once your mail is ready just
pick up or just schedule a pickup or
drop it off it is indeed
that simple with stamps.com you get
discounts up to 40 off postage rates
post office rates and up to 62 percent
off ups shipping rates and again
stamps.com fraction of the cost of the
expensive
postage meters it's a no-brainer we've
been using it for a while i use it in my
house even
go check out stamps.com right now with
my promo code shapiro you get a special
offer it includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and digital scale
no long-term commitments no contracts
just head on over to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office
again all right in a second we're going
to get to the democrats and their
absolute
raging fiery hypocrisy on getting rid of
the own
their own bad actors and how they are
taking advantage of the marjory taylor
green thing to push politically
we'll get to that in a second first your
chance to get 25
off a new daily wire membership with
code rhf it is fading fast pay like fast
sign up today
watch our first feature film run hide
fight run hide fight
let our debut into the world of
entertainment a few weeks ago it is an
excellent
action thriller about a high school girl
about to graduate
and she just wants to get through the
last three weeks of high school and then
her school
is hit by a concerted school shooting
attack and she has to fight back against
it it is pretty fantastic
run high fight it's available
exclusively to daily wire members
right now if you want to watch it use
code rhf to get 25 off your membership
today remind our audiences they're
loving it you go over to rotten tomatoes
you'll notice it's like 25
from critics and 93 from the general
public
that is the kind of stuff that we are
are going to produce here at daily wire
the stuff that you love but critics say
because it ain't woke this promo is only
available through the weekend
so this is your last chance i mean it's
attending right now use code rhf
get 25 off your membership at dailywire
join us in the culture war
today you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile the democrats they
are pushing forward
with their agenda with regard to this
sort of stuff
right they're just blatant and raging
hypocrites when it comes to holding
their own members to account i'm getting
very tired of the argument from the left
that we are so good at holding our
members to account you guys never hold
your members to account name
the last democrat who's held to account
seriously can you name one
i cannot name one okay there have been
democrats who have resigned because
they're alleged to have actually done
things but it's not because they were
being held to account
by their own caucus and in fact a lot of
them have now buyers remorse like the
only person who comes to mind in the
recent past
is uh is is maybe al franken and now
franken has buyer's remorse and he's
like i really shouldn't have done that
by the way the reason they capped al
franken way back when is because they
were attempting to establish a metoo
standard they couldn't actually uphold
because they want to go after trump in
any case
nancy pelosi puts out a statement
calling kevin mccarthy mccarthy
qca okay
because of q and on get it he's not r c
a it's like when i call
alexander ocasio-cortez d twitch because
i think that her actual constituency is
is on twitch not in new york so
according to
according to um nancy pelosi kevin
mccarthy is now an advocate of q
which is weird since he has condemned q
many many many times but in any case
she puts out a statement saying after
several conversations and literally
running away from reporters
minority leader kevin mccarthy qca like
i can't believe these are the adults in
the room
these are the adults in the room yeah
slow clap for unity and
and adulting here made clear he was
refusing to take action against
conspiracy theorist representative
marjorie taylor greene as a result the
house will continue with the vote to
strip green of her seat
on the esteemed house committee on
education and labor and the house
committee on budget first of all there's
no such thing as an esteemed house
committee they all suck
mccarthy's failure to lead his party
effectively hands the keys over to green
an anti-semite q anon adherent and 911
truther
as number two senate republican john
thune warned tuesday mccarthy has chosen
to make the house republicans the party
of conspiracy theories and q and on and
representative greene is in the driver's
seat okay
the irony of nancy pelosi saying this
after turning over her entire party to
ilhan omar
aoc and rashida talib is beyond the pale
it's insanity
it's insanity okay so here's the thing
when nancy pelosi makes the contention
that republicans are now the party of
marjory taylor green because they didn't
strip her of committee assignments
let me just point out ilhan omar was on
the cover of like is mccarthy gonna pose
on the cover of rolling stone
with marjorie taylor green i think not
and yet nancy pelosi did exactly then
she took like a vacation she took like a
congressional junket with ilhan omar
they like cutesy little instagram videos
meanwhile ilhan omar is trying to run
away from the implication that she has
anything like
marjorie taylor green she says you know
i'm not like that they're just
scapegoating me because i'm black and
because i'm muslim
nope it's cause you're an anti-semite
that's why because
you are a you are a not good person
who's anti-semitic
radical in every incarnation i can think
of
that is why people went after you you
know hiding behind the identity politics
ain't gonna work here
but she's my favorite thing here i love
this she says they're
they're doing this because they're
trying to scapegoat me because they are
misogynists
and and racists and islamophobes right
she put out a statement she said let's
be clear this is a desperate smear
rooted in racism misogyny and
islamophobia
no no also if it's rooted in misogyny
i'm just wondering
uh why exactly are you guys going after
margaret taylor green she's a woman is
that rooted in misogyny or is it legit
serious real question marjorie taylor
green has incited violence against her
fellow members of congress repeatedly
singling out prominent women of color
she actively encouraged the insurrection
on the capital that threatened my life
in the life of every member of congress
and resulted
in multiple deaths she ran a campaign ad
holding an assault rifle next to my face
she came to the capitol demanding that
me
and representative philippe and i swear
in on the christian bible instead of the
quran
granted i don't like any of those things
those things are all bad things
you should not have committee
assignments also you're a blatant
routine anti-semite who says insanely
radical things and you also should not
have a committee assignment
the house republican caucus instead of
holding her accountable is now fanning
the flames
okay again the the irony here is just
too much to bear i'm sorry oh and omar
calling out the republican caucus for
not ousting their most radical members
and by a mirror lady seriously as
ilhan omar then went on msnbc and said
their entire republican base is looney
tunes
the entire republican base at grifters
cowards
this is she's the there are no words
there are no words here she was on msnbc
their party is destroyed
uh their base now is conspiracy
theorists
it's cowards it's opportunists
it's grifters and sadly um they're
becoming the looney tunes you know these
are
uh people who we can't take serious
rashida talib did the same thing so
another blatant anti-semite you
can't compare ilhan omar to marjory
taylor green
she says let's be clear this false
equivalency is a pathetically desperate
smear
rooted in racism misogyny and
islamophobia my favorite thing is when
uh rashidali nilhan and umar like just
literally copy each other's statements
and tweets
that that's always fun but rashida talib
should not be on committees either
so that's fun meanwhile the republican
party did take a vote last night
on liz cheney's there's been a lot of
blowback against liz cheney the number
three in the house the representative
from wyoming there's this vote in the
house republican caucus about whether
she should be stripped
of her title as house gop conference
chair it was a secret ballot
now the reason it was a secret ballot is
because unfortunately there are too many
republican congress people
who are afraid of their own constituents
and believe their constituents would be
mad if they found out that they voted in
favor of liz cheney that's that's
silliness it shouldn't have been held
anonymously and they should have voted
exactly the same way
but in any case the vote was held it was
not particularly close
the way the media characterized this is
cheney holds on to house leadership
position
no she didn't hold on the vote among
house republican members was 145 to 61
not to strip her of the position meaning
the vast majority of republicans are
like okay i may disagree with you on
impeachment but
that is not a reason why you should lose
the number three seat in the in the
house
gop coalition cheney spoke briefly to
reporters after she held on to her title
she said we really did have a terrific
bow tonight a terrific time this evening
laying out what we are going to do going
forward as well as making clear we're
not going to be divided we're not going
to be in a situation where people can
pick off any member of leadership it was
a resounding acknowledgement that we
need to go forward together and we need
to go forward in a way that helps us
beat back the really dangerous and
negative
democratic policies so the
this is a rebuttal to the argument
that's been made by the media that liz
cheney was going to that this is the
party of marjory taylor green and
knotless cheney there was only one vote
that was held last night
and it was on liz cheney not on marjory
taylor grade if there'd been a vote held
inside the republican caucus on marjory
taylor green
i think there's a good shot that
marjorie taylor green will lost her
committee assignments i think mccarthy
didn't hold that because he doesn't like
dividing the caucus
or he wants to hold together the caucus
in the same way that pelosi wants to
hold together her caucus
mccarthy is uh concerned with some of
the republican base
only about 30 percent of the again only
about 30 percent of the republicans
voted against liz cheney retaining
that particular seat and my guess is
that it wouldn't be a significantly
higher number
saying that marge retailer greens should
retain her committee ship but in any
case it does kill the democratic
narrative
which is that this is not the party of
liz cheney anymore it's the party of
marjory taylor green the answer is
right now for better or for worse i
think
for better sometimes and for worse
sometimes also uh it is the party
of both and that means that the the
party needs to do a better job of
dissociating
from the radical belief system of
marjorie taylor and she did apologize
okay she did say that she doesn't
believe that stuff anymore
so that is better than not apologizing
now let's just see some proof in the
pudding
meaning how about like not saying crazy
crap for several months or ever again
that would be a good way to go so that
is where things stand inside
the republican caucus as of now the
democrats are going to take a vote in
the house today to strip margaret taylor
green
for committee assignments the goal of
that is to get republicans on record
voting either for or against stripping
marjorie taylor green for committee
assignments this is why i think it was a
bad move by mccarthy
not to just strip it preemptively from
marjory taylor green because now they're
going to be forced on record
anyway the talking point is going to be
you voted in favor of the q anon lady
and that is not a a talk again i'm
always
bewildered by republicans who are like
yeah but the democrats don't strip
illinois
yeah and what a talking point that's
been for conservatives has it not
right that has been a pretty solid
talking point i mean donald trump
thought that was a solid talking point
for conservatives
it's the reason he kept saying this is
the party of ilhan omar and rashida
talib
so how about this how about stand up
against the crazies in your own party
this should hold true on both sides
unfortunately it seems to uh hold true
on neither more often than not
these days alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content
coming up soon matt wall show airing at
1 30 pm eastern be sure
to check it out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producers are
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager pava wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica crand the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show